let's talk to mark strassman why because
he's been here before he knows how this
works you told me yesterday
hi mark hi good morning you told me
yesterday wait till you see this this is
going to be so cool i feel the electric
the electricity in the air the
enthusiasm and just coming this morning
you were so right and just imagine what
these four passengers i know i've been
thinking about that they're they're on
site now probably getting suited up i
mean this is a huge day it's both
look it's both a moment and a milestone
for everybody
involved for jeff bezos personally of
course he's dreamed about going to space
since he was a kid
but also for blue origin for space
tourism
and for the short-term future of
commercial space
feels good to be in the flight suit when
he launches into space
jeff bezos will be giving his company's
product the ultimate endorsement
riding on a fully automated rocket that
has never before
carried a human to the edge of space
we set out to create the safest human
space flight vehicle ever designed or
built
or operated gary lie's team designed
blue origin space approach
from the single stage reusable rocket to
the autonomous capsule
to the landing system its safety
features include three breaking
parachutes
and thrusters to slow the capsule right
before landing
to one mile per hour if only one chute
opened
would the people inside survive yes the
capsule is designed to be survivable if
only one of the main parachutes
opens the retro rocket will do the do
its its utmost to slow the vehicle down
but then there is a crushable structure
at the bottom of the capsule that will
absorb
some of the impact and then the seat has
a
energy absorb absorption mechanism a
scissor mechanism
that then takes the astronaut and
decelerates them at a safe
velocity inside this simulator we saw
another safety feature
its integrated autonomous escape system
this is our
escape motor if there is any issue
detected with the rocket
we will fire this escape motor to get
the capsule far and fast away from the
booster
and they've made sure it works at every
stage of the mission
on the launch pad in flight and all the
way in space
in all 15 test flights the capsule
returns safely to the ground
four people will ride into space this
morning but this moment caps
two decades of perseverance at blue
origin
there's a lot of people hundreds of
engineers over the years that have
worked on this vehicle so this is a
culmination of a dream for them
bezos wants blue origin eventually to go
to the moon and ultimately to colonize
the cosmos
but this company has a step-by-step
discipline and today's step
is for the first time sending humans up
into space
and bringing them back safely we had an
interesting moment
fun moment yesterday in the media center
the bezos brothers jeff and mark
came in carrying trays of food it was
chicken with rice they said it was their
grandmother's
recipe they were very upbeat very
confident i asked jeff bezos at one
point
are you excited to say yeah i'm excited
i'm really excited i mean you really
have the sense gail
that uh these folks genuinely believe
it's all systems go
yes and they are ready yes i mean when
you're even talking to the team today
it seems like they have dotted every eye
and crossed every t they are so psyched
but i'm wondering mark does this ever
get old i can't get over
listen i get excited watching a launch
at home in my pajamas
you know that moment where they lift off
to see and make sure that they get off
safely
i can't imagine what it's like to see it
in person listen we're about three miles
or so away but you say we'll be able to
see it
does this ever get old to be here for
this i think it's always
one of the most dynamic man-made
moments you can ever experience both the
sight of it the sound of it the
realization of
that there are lives riding on this
rocket i mean it's
it is it is something that's you're in
for a treat
i believe you mark strausman thank you